workout this one's free
she's been inspiring folks on amazon
through her free 15 minute online
workouts for years now she's tripling
the fun adding a little 80s flare i
recently had the chance to chat with
maggie binkley about her free workout
event that she's hosting on saturday
take a listen
so tell me about this event that's
happening on saturday and so pacific
time it would be 8 a.m
what is it and how can we get involved
yeah so it's going to be a really fun
virtual workout i made it 80s themed
because
that's fun right i'm going to be wearing
some leg warmers some wristbands it's
going to be fun but it's totally
optional to dress up of course um but
yeah i'm going to make it
really great 45 minute workout so it's
not one of my traditional 15 minute
workouts but on the weekends i like to
give something a little longer and i
thought this would be a really great way
to get people involved and just kind of
see what it's like to work out with me
and make the most of a saturday morning
and have some fun together because
fitness should be fun make you smile
make you sweat and challenge you all at
once i love it because having done so
many of your workouts i know they're
difficult but i know you give you know
different variations for people of all
different fitness levels so this is
geared really to anyone
do you need any kind of equipment
yeah no so no equipment if you have a
mat that be helpful but you absolutely
don't need any equipment at all and
speaking to that yes so my workouts are
for all fitness levels i try to make it
so that no matter whether you are a
beginner or if you're super advanced
that you're going to come work out with
me and be challenged no matter what so
i'll give options to modify to advance
to go low impact to go high impact if
that's an option um and just make the
most of your time there with me so
basically i just want you to get the
greatest workout that you can no matter
your fitness level and have a lot of fun
doing it now you're doing a contest for
best dressed is that right
sure thing so if you choose to turn your
camera on there will be a prize for best
address i figured why not right it's
it's fine let's make it let's make it
more fun it's the 80s baby okay
we're ready to go but just tell me how
can folks find you how can they register
yeah absolutely so my website is
fitnessmaggie.com
and there'll be a little pop-up that'll
come up for you to actually rsvp so you
just have to rsvp to the zoom event it's
completely free no obligation at all
you're not signing up for anything
otherwise and then
you'll receive an email you'll get the
rsvp so you can just click join when we
head there and actually
joining about 30 minutes ahead of time
wonderful maggie binkley star of amazon
prime's 15 minute workouts which are
hard and fun we appreciate your time
this morning have a great event on
saturday
absolutely thank you so much i'm really
excited i look forward to seeing
everybody there